if you're above a certain age you know
that miami vice was once the coolest
show on tv whether you're old enough to
remember it or not keep watching to find
out what made it so cool
miami vice was unlike anything else on
the air when it premiered in 1984. the
series sprung from the mind of nbc
entertainment president brandon tardikov
after being inspired by mtv the most
revolutionary thing on 80s television at
the time was mtv the network which at
the time aired music videos 24 hours a
day tardikov wanted nbc to cash in on
the craze and while brainstorming ideas
one day he wrote down two simple words
mtv cops he sent along this tiny memo to
hill street blues writer and producer
anthony yurkovich yurkovich immediately
started to work on a project that could
fit tartakov's vague description
yurkovich had gotten the idea for a
movie about police officers in miami
working vice aka the beat for drugs and
prostitution he turned it into a double
episode length pilot script initially
titled gold coast speaking to time in
1985 yurkovich had this to say about the
idea even when i was on hill street
blues i was collecting information on
miami it seemed to be an interesting
socio-economic tide pool the incredible
number of refugees from central america
and cuba the already extensive
cuban-american community and on top of
all that the drug trade
don johnson has scored some notable
parts since spending six years starring
as sonny crockett on miami vice he
played the title character on the light
in tone cop drama nash bridges and later
had to turn as a police chief with dark
secrets on hbo's watchman but he'll
likely never move out of the large
shadow cast by his big miami vice gig so
it's baffling to think that nbc almost
went another way brandon tartikov pushed
hard to cast larry wilcox's sonny
crockett on miami vice at the time
wilcox was just wrapping up a long run
as a motorcycle riding highway patrolman
on chips wilcox auditioned and filmed
some fight-based test shots for miami
vice only for them to cast johnson
instead who was just coming off of five
unsold pilots at one point the show's
producers toyed with casting two major
movie stars of the time jeff bridges and
nick nolte
part of what made miami vice so
different from other police and crime
shows of the 1980s was its look and by
look we mean the unique grooming style
and fashion forward clothes of don
johnson's character sunny crockett i
mean
not exactly up my alley style and
persona wise
heaven knows i'm no box of candy he
wasn't clean shaven and he didn't rock
an era appropriate mustache however he
did sport the fuzzy beginnings of a
beard as if he hadn't had a chance to
shave in a while johnson talked to
rolling stone about the look saying the
stubble was born out of the character
because it was intimated that he had
been up partying with drug dealers for
two or three days at a time that was
sort of an unspoken thing which is why
he was always unshaven and looked like
he slept in his clothes as for those
clothes countless guys co-opted the
sunny crockett look a light-colored
blazer over a bright t-shirt as well as
shoes with no socks all of those choices
were just practical johnson added the
rolled up sleeves was a function of the
fact that i had to have a jacket to
cover the gun in the holster i just
stripped everything down to the bare
minimum i didn't wear socks because it
was too hot to wear damn socks after all
they were in miami
the popularity of miami vice peaked in
its second season for the year of 1985
to 86 it ranked number nine in the
nielsen ratings nbc naturally ordered up
a third season but starred don johnson
bulked at his salary the 35 000 per
episode he'd been making up to that
point was commensurate for an actor on a
new show not the mega star of an ultra
successful hit according to the
associated press johnson wanted to raise
to upwards of one hundred thousand
dollars per episode he feuded with his
bosses at universal television and
refused to report to work until he got
what he wanted executives called his
bluff filing a 10 million dollar breach
of contract lawsuit and leaking the news
that they were prepared to let johnson
leave the series they even had two
potential actor replacements lined up
saying elsewhere star mark harmon and
the rising tree williams shortly after
those aggressive actions the parties
worked out a mutually agreeable
arrangement johnson returned to the
miami vice set as a newly minted member
of tv's highest paid actors club
show creator anthony yurkovich
supervised the pilot and first five
episodes of miami vice then moved on to
make movies for universal pictures this
left the many day-to-day operations in
the hands of executive producer michael
mann the show was so young and
relatively undeveloped that man could
greatly dictate its direction
particularly its visual style and pastel
heavy color palette man sought to
express miami's uniquely bright and
eye-popping look on camera inspired by
memories of the city from a mid-70s
vacation as well as a random trip to a
paint store one time when he was looking
at color chips he shared this experience
with the los angeles times i was playing
around with the chips and i realized
three colors become thematic two colors
don't three colors you can actually
start telling a chromatic story you can
create a mood with three colors as a
result miami vice employed a strict hues
policy miami vice episode director bobby
roth told time there are certain colors
you're not allowed to shoot such as red
and brown michael knows how things are
going to look on camera a lot of it is
very basic stuff that has never been
applied to tv miami vice was to use the
language of then and now both cool and
hot it was so cool that its theme song
for a time became the hottest pop song
in the land the extended version of
miami vice theme written and performed
by jan hammer went to number one on the
billboard hot 100 in november 1985. even
though hammer never made it to the pop
chart again his composition is still one
of only five tv theme songs to ever sit
atop the top 40. as well as hammer's
theme song performed the first miami
vice soundtrack album did even better
released in 1985 the record included
hammer's theme song and other bits of
incidental music along with pop songs
prominently featured on the series
including glenn frey's you belong to the
city and phil collins in the air tonight
it spent 11 weeks at number one in the
billboard album chart and sold 4 million
copies ranking it among the most
successful tv tie-in albums of all time
there's an old saying about how
imitation is the sincerest form of
flattery which means the people who made
miami vice must have been very touched
when the airwaves were flooded with
rip-offs in 1985 a year after nbc
premiered miami vice abc answered with
the insiders which it claimed offered
contemporary music and a highly stylized
visual approach nicholas campbell and
stoney jackson starred as edgy crime
reporter nick fox and an ex-con turned
informant named mackie in true vice
style the pilot episode contained fancy
cars a visceral sequence depicting a
seedy crime and almost everybody dressed
in hip clothes the insiders was canceled
after 13 episodes and abc's other vice
clone hollywood beat only lasted 14.
miami vice also helped lead to one of
the most beloved and successful sitcoms
of all time older actress doris roberts
and selma diamond performed a bit during
an event announcing nbc's
1984-85 season and joked that they were
starring on a show called miami nice
that gave tartakov an idea a show about
retirement age women all living together
in miami that show which hit the network
in 1985 to ratings and critical success
was none other than the golden girls
when miami vice debuted in 1984 the real
city of miami wasn't as glamorous and
flashy as the show made it seem
according to the miami herald the city
was recovering from riots and struggling
to house a large number of haitian
refugees drug cartels were gaining power
and influence and violent crime was
dramatically rising but miami vice made
miami's run-down art deco architectural
style look cool and vital that's a big
part of what makes the city's south
beach nightlife district so attractive
to this day crews fixed up and painted
over the doled with time exteriors of
disused buildings providing miami with a
free makeover that was revitalizing and
restorative don johnson talked about
this makeover to rolling stone saying we
painted the facades of virtually every
building up and down collins avenue and
ocean avenue to match the color palettes
we had for the show the whole town kind
of reinvented itself in the image of a
television show all those reworked
buildings allowed new business in miami
to flourish turning south beach into a
tourist destination which initially
catered to big fans of miami vice
not only did crockett and tubs dress
cool they drove cool too since they
frequently were going undercover and had
access to sweet wheels that the mpd
seized from drug lords the cops of miami
vice got to drive some enviable
automobiles detective stance wytek drove
a 1963 ford thunderbird detective tubbs
had a 1963 cadillac deville and
detective crockett initially cruised
with a ferrari 365 gtb4 daytona spider
according to popular mechanics
crockett's car wasn't actually a ferrari
instead it was custom made for the show
assembled out of a 1980 corvette with
some ferrari parts this car garnered so
much attention from fans and car lovers
that it rubbed executives at ferrari the
wrong way ferrari north america sought
to divert attention away from a car that
wasn't commercially available so they
provided two brand new ferrari testers
to the miami vice production the
testerosas arrived painted black but
when the cars didn't look good in some
of the show's many nighttime scenes the
crew threw on some white paint
what did all those things that made
miami vice so fresh and original
actually cost they cost a lot in the
first season of the show producers spent
about 1.3 million dollars per episode
that's 30 percent more than what other
police series spent for an installment
at the time when adjusted to today's
current dollar value miami vice cost 3.1
million dollars an episode and that's
before don johnson's big pay raise a
substantial segment of the budget each
week went to music early in its run
miami vice soundtrack supervisors spent
about ten thousand dollars each week to
license pre-existing well-known pop and
rock songs by the likes of u2 tina
turner phil collins and roxymusic that
costs a lot more than just hiring studio
musicians to make a generic soft rock
score
miami vice faded into the collective
turquoise and pink tinted memory in 1989
after falling to number 64 in the annual
nielsen ratings no longer the white hot
show it was just a few years earlier by
the mid 2000s the franchise's good name
had switched from passe to nostalgia and
series executive producer michael mann
had evolved into an accomplished and
louded filmmaker all of this however
made for the perfect climate for a miami
vice revival on the big screen according
to kinetoscope the film's production was
anything but perfect going over budget
and enduring filming delays star jamie
foxx grew so disenchanted that he left
the film during a location shoot in the
dominican republic and refused to come
back for any overseas work this forced
man to rewrite the ending and abandon
plans to shoot in paraguay fox and man
really didn't get along but that wasn't
an isolated situation according to a
crew member michael dressed down
everybody and humiliated everybody
audiences likely used to campy ironic
movie versions of era definitive tv
shows seemingly weren't ready for a
gritty dark r-rated drug trafficking
thriller critics weren't either and
reviewed it tepidly at the time the 2006
film earned a middling 63 million
dollars at the domestic box office less
than half of the film's enormous 135
million dollar budget
if filmmakers or producers had any plans
to bring back miami vice in the wake of
the 2006 film version the movie's
lackluster performance likely buried
those plans in the ground but 2006 is a
millennium ago to hollywood and in the
2010s talks started happening on giving
miami vice another high profile shot in
2014 universal pictures actively
accepted pitches from screenwriters who
wanted to take a shot at launching a new
franchise of crockett and tubbs
headlined adventures those films
unfortunately never came but later that
year original series star don johnson
told rolling stone that there was quote
talk recently about doing new episodes
and that he had a few ideas on how to
pass the torch narratively speaking to a
new generation of vice cops in 2017
nearly three years later after those
negotiations allegedly took place
variety reported that movie star vin
diesel and producer chris morgan were
hard at work on a new miami vice for nbc
tv writer peter mcmanus who'd penned
episodes of the mist and satisfaction
was hired to write the pilot script but
that new take on miami vice never showed
up either check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies and tv
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]
you